[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis 40 jours depuis 40 nuits nous
nous sommes embarqués avec quelques amis
sur la péniche bleue de la vieille Zoé
qui nous emmène au loin même si l'on
reste àqué dans l'ARGE de Zoé on oublie
nos soucis en écoutant
nous raconter sa vie dans l'Arche de Zoé
on chante on boit on rit car l'Arche de
Zoé c'est presque un
paradis depuis 40 jours depuis 40 nuit
nous attendons la fin du déluge d'ennui
moitié lion moitié lour par cette vie de
chien mais chacun chez Zoé a confiance
en demain dans la arge Zoë on noublie no
souci en éant Zoë nous raconter sa vie
dans l'Arche de Zoé on chante on boit on
rit car l'Arche de Zoé c'est presque un
paradis depuis 40 jours depuis 40 nuits
j'attends le grand retour de ma
colombeami c'est une belle fille qui
revient le printemps mepporter la joie
l'amour entre les dents dans
l'argeé on ouv nos sou en écoutant Zoé
nous raconter sa vie dans l'Arche de Zoé
en chant voir hor car l'arche de soé
c'est notre paradis dans l'arche de soé
on oublie nos souc
on nous raconter sa vie dans l'arche
de G on voir hor car l'arche de soë
c'est notre
[Musique]
paradis